just a few years ago most scientists
believe that supernovas were cataclysmic
enough to do the job but astronomer IDO
burger was not so sure if you open any
one of these books and flip to the page
that tells you where gold came from it
will tell you that gold came from
supernova explosions but nobody had
directly observed supernovas producing
elements like gold and inside computer
simulations virtual supernovas lack the
energy to forge these oversized atoms
clearly something was wrong but if
supernovas weren't powerful enough what
in the universe was the forum heavy
elements requires a lot of neutrons and
so another possible theory was that the
heaviest elements were produced in the
mergers of two neutron stars in a binary
system
neutron stars are some of the weirdest
objects in the universe they're formed
from the collapsed cores of big stars
when they die you're taking a couple of
times the mass of the Sun and squeezing
it down into a bulb it's only a few
miles across the electrons and the
protons that are flitting around inside
of that combine to form neutrons and
what you're left with is an extremely
dense ball of neutrons about the size of
a city neutron stars are extremely dense
if you take just a teaspoon of the
neutron star material it's actually a
billion tons
if neighboring stars die together it's
possible for the two neutron star as
they leave behind to form a spinning
binary pair but the partnership is
doomed what you're left over with is two
incredibly compact dramatic objects
spiraling around each other
over time they move in together until
finally they can coalesce in the most
violent explosion since the Big Bang the
explosion is called a neutron star
merger the amount of energy in this
explosion is crushing there's almost no
way to describe it it's like taking all
of the sun's energy that it will ever
emit over its entire lifetime and
releasing it in a single second Berger
suspects this colossal explosion forges
iridium gold and lead but to rewrite the
textbooks he needs hard evidence it was
difficult to convince the community that
this was a potential channel for the
production of heavy elements the proof
is to actually see this process
happening in the universe
June 2013 NASA's Swift satellite spots a
short burst of gamma rays from a nearby
galaxy a sure sign that a neutron star
merger has just taken place for burger
it's the lucky break
he's been waiting for as soon as we knew
that there was a gamma-ray burst nearby
we knew that this was our one chance for
perhaps several years to obtain the
right kind of measurements to test the
formation of heavy elements